[موسيقى]
انتشار امني كثيف في جزيره جربه
هجوم استهدف كنيسا يهوديا اثار فزع
الزائرين والاهالي وانتهى بوقوع قتلى
ومصابين الداخليه التونسيه وبعد سيطره
قواتها الامنيه على مداخل ومخارج الجزيره
اوضحت تفاصيل الهجوم وقالت ان عنصرا من
الحرس البحري الوطني قتل احد زملائه
باستعمال سلاحه الفردي واستولى على
الذخيره ثم عمد الى اطلاق النار عشوائيا
على الوحدات الامنيه المتمركزه في معبد
جربه قبل ان تتمكن قوات الامن من قتله
مواجهات تسببت بوقوع اصابات بينهم سته من
رجال الامن والمدنيين احدهم فرنسي الجنسيه
التحقيقات الاوليه اوضحت ان دوافع الهجوم
تمثلت باستهداف وجهه سياحيه شهيره تقع
قباره الساحل الجنوبي لتونس وهي في الوقت
ذاته تمثل موطرا للجاليه اليهوديه في
البلاد
الهجوم اثار مخاوف من امكانيه انعكاسه على
عدم استقرار الامن خاصه مع دخول موسم
السياحه الذي تترقبه تونس لتحسين اقتصادها
بشكل تدريجي
الخارجيه الامريكيه استنكرت هجوم جربه
واشادت بالتحرك السريع للقوات الامنيه
فيما اعتبرته الخارجيه الفرنسيه هجوم
شنيعا يذكر بالهجوم الانتحاري الذي اوقع
واحدا وعشرين قتيلا في المعبد نفسه قبل
اكثر من عقدين من خلال سياره مفخخه زج بها
عناصر القاعده لتفجير المعبد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات